Je suis fils d'éleveur.
Quand j'étais enfant,
chaque jour après l'école,
j'allais garder le bétail,
Le bétail, c'est toute ma vie.
Je ne sais rien faire d'autre.
Le cri d'appel des pasteurs peuls.
Pendant combien de temps les grandes
ethnies d'éleveurs africains,
peuls et arabes, vont-elles pouvoir
continuer à parcourir librement,
les grandes plaines du continent ?
Pour conduire leurs troupeaux
de points d'eau en point d'eau,
à la recherche de précieux pâturages.
Dans notre monde en rapide évolution,
que vont devenir ces bergers
qui depuis des siècles,
ont réussi à acclimater
leurs zébus et leurs moutons,
à des régions arides et inhospitalières ?
Et à développer une forme d'élevage
souple et autonome.
Les effets de la mondialisation
se font sentir jusque dans les régions,
les plus rurales et isolées d'Afrique.
Ils menacent aujourd'hui des cultures
ancestrales, restées longtemps protégées.
L'avenir de ces nomades
libre et autonome,
est remis en question dans un monde,
où l'économie de marché fait loi.
Un monde où les changements climatiques
entraînent des  sécheresses à répétition.
Un monde où une augmentation
démographique spectaculaire,
exige des États africains qu'ils
puissent approvisionner en viande,
des populations urbaines
de plus en plus exigeantes.
Un monde où la contemplation
et la liberté de mouvement et de pensée,
n'ont plus leur place.
On a trop de difficultés !
Pour Hassan, ça fait 60 ans.
Pour moi, ça fait 35 ans.
Avant, c'était très bien
parce qu'il y avait assez de pâturages.
Mais actuellement, il n'y en a plus.
Les routes sont barrées.
Nous n'avons pas de quoi
faire boire nos troupeaux.
Alors que la demande en viande augmente,
la situation des éleveurs se dégrade.
Les premiers touchés
sont les éleveurs peuls,
appartenant à la grande ethnie
originaire de Nubie.
Les bergers transhumants du
Sahel, qui se comptent par millions,
fournissent toujours l'essentiel
de la viande rouge,
consommée en Afrique
centrale et occidentale.
Mais leur liberté de mouvement
est aujourd'hui remise en question,
ce qui les met face
à de terribles défis,
et un avenir incertain.
L'alimentation du bétail en zone
sahélienne, repose quasiment,
à 95% sur le pâturage naturel.
Qui n'est pas très important
et qui n'est pas très productif,
400 à 800 kilos de matière sèche.
Et qui subit les aléas climatiques.
Donc là, il s'agit surtout,
de maintenir la transhumance
qui est le moyen,
d'aller chercher l'herbe où elle
est une année et pas une autre.
Ce déplacement est un système
pour pallier les sécheresses,
et les risques inhérents à l'élevage
et à l'alimentation du bétail.
Et puis dans les zones plus sahéliennes,
ces éleveurs sont les seuls
qui peuvent mettre en valeur,
des terres qui ne peuvent être
mises en valeur que par des animaux,
qui vont chercher de l'aliment
et qui reviennent,
le transformer en viande qui est vendue.
On ne peut pas faire de l'agriculture sauf
à tomber dans les problèmes oasien,
avec de l'irrigation, mais on
ne peut pas faire des oasis partout.
La production animale est la seule
qui peut valoriser ces zones marginales.
À Dakar, un pôle de recherche sur
l'élevage pastoral en zones sèches,
a été créé depuis une dizaine d'années.
Son terrain d'action s'étend
du Sénégal au Tchad,
et son équipe s'efforce de faire
comprendre aux Etats africains,
les atouts des systèmes d'élevage
traditionnels transhumants.
Dans un contexte économique,
dans un contexte écologique,
à mon avis, il n'y a pas d'autre
système qui permettrait,
de produire mieux que ce que
nos éleveurs font actuellement.
Il suffit juste,
par rapport aux objectifs de l'Etat,
par rapport au problème qui se pose,
de l'augmentation de la démographie.
Il y a aussi un besoin
de produire davantage,
de pouvoir accompagner ce système
au même titre que l'Etat le fait,
pour les autres systèmes de production.
Au Tchad, pendant la saison des pluies,
les éleveurs nomades occupent
les grands espaces du nord du pays,
des espaces qui
se couvrent alors d'herbe,
comme c'est le cas près
de la ville de Moussoro.
Mais à l'automne, lorsque la saison
sèche reprend ses droits,
les éleveurs sont obligés
de se replier vers le sud,
à la recherche de nouveaux pâturages.
Les éleveurs nomades entament une longue
transhumance de près de 500 km.
En longeant le lac Tchad,
puis les fleuves Chari et Logone
jusqu'au sud de la ville de N'Djamena.
Tous les jours, les rives du Logone
sont le théâtre d'un impressionnant ballet.
Des dizaines de pasteurs peuls et arabes
y amènent boire leurs zébus,
leurs chameaux ainsi
que leurs chèvres et moutons.
Comme de nombreuses familles
d'éleveurs nomades,
Alagi Shama et les siens ont établi
leur campement à Maibodo.
Une zone très convoitée par les agriculteurs
et les éleveurs transhumants.
Idéalement situé à 3 km du fleuve.
Ici, comme un peu partout dans le pays,
les zones de pâturage
et les couloirs de transhumance,
créés il y a plusieurs siècles
au profit des éleveurs nomades,
ne sont plus guère respectés
par le reste de la population.
Alagi Shama est peul.
Comme tous les éleveurs de son ethnie,
il ne connaît pas le nombre
exact de ses bêtes,
mais il connaît chacune
d'elles par son nom.
À la seconde où un animal disparaît,
il le sent et il sait lequel.
Les bêtes sont la raison
de vivre des Peuls,
et leur principale source d'alimentation
à travers le lait de leur vache.
Actuellement en saison sèche,
nous avons besoin qu'on nous facilite
l'accès au  pâturages.
Nous avons sans arrêt des problèmes pour
accéder au terrain et au point d'eau.
Le problème, c'est tous
ces champs cultivés.
Si les cultivateurs font leurs champs ici,
ça nous oblige à aller plus loin,
où il n'y a plus de cultures.
Il n'y a plus de place ici pour nous.
C'est notre plus grand problème.
Ils se mettent tous
à cultiver dans ce coin.
J'ai compris comment le monde
marche aujourd'hui.
Si tu ne possèdes pas ta propre terre,
demain, tu seras repoussé
dans un coin difficile.
C'est ce que je peux prévoir.
C'est pour cela que nous devons acheter
de la terre partout où c'est possible.
Ce pays a oublié ses éleveurs.
Au Tchad, il n'existe pas de loi qui
organise la transhumance.
Il n'y a qu'une loi qui
date du 31 octobre 1959.
Elle est très ancienne et inadaptée
aux conditions actuelles.
La population
et le bétail ont augmenté.
La progression du désert a aussi
provoqué l'arrivée d'autres éleveurs,
dans des zones autrefois
réservées aux Peuls.
Les anciennes routes
de transhumance sont fermées.
Les nouveaux couloirs sont devenus
des champs cultivés.
C'est à l'origine de
ce que les gens appellent,
des conflits agriculteurs-éleveurs.
L'insuffisance de pâturages et le
manque d'eau pour abreuver le bétail,
pousse les éleveurs a installé
leur campement autour des villages.
Normalement, l'état devrait
forer des puits, loin des villages,
et préserver des zones de pâturage.
Comme les éleveurs sont obligés
d'utiliser les puits des villages,
ça pose des problèmes.
Souvent, les villageois considèrent
que si les éleveurs se servent,
ils n'auront pas assez d'eau pour eux,
et que si les éleveurs veulent
de l'eau, ils doivent la payer.
Parfois, cela provoque des conflits
avec les éleveurs transhumants,
et ça peut même dégénérer en bagarres,
avec des morts.
Les autorités locales en profitent
pour dramatiser le conflit,
en rendant les agriculteurs
victimes des éleveurs.
Les difficultés que rencontrent
les éleveurs en général sont nombreuses.
Celles que rencontrent
les Peuls sont pires encore.
Parce que partout où ils
installent leur campement,
ils ne jouissent d'aucun droit.
Ils sont rackettés par les autorités
des localités voisines,
ils donnent des amendes, sans raison.
Certains ont même été tués.
D'autres ont perdu leur bétail.
Ça arrive tout le temps lors
des conflits avec les agriculteurs.
Non seulement on doit leur payer
une amende de 2000 francs CFA,
Mais on doit verser 5000,
ou 10 000 de plus aux autorités.
L'agriculteur prend l'argent.
Et les autorités aussi.
Pour l'agriculteur ça normal,
il a subi des dégâts.
C'est le supplément pour
les autorités qui nous fait mal.
On ne comprend pas.
L'argent taxé par les autorités,
ça nous dépasse.
Tous les vendredis, les éleveurs peuls,
se réunissent pour  prier
et se donner les dernières nouvelles.
Ils profitent du passage des représentants
de leur association de nomades,
pour leur faire part de leurs doléances.
Depuis quelques années, au Tchad, comme dans
tous les pays de la région sahélienne,
des associations se sont
peu à peu constituées,
pour défendre les droits
des éleveurs peuls.
Que la paix soit avec vous.
Nous, les éleveurs tchadiens,
on ne nous laisse jamais tranquilles,
que ce soit le gouvernement
ou les agriculteurs.
Même quand on arrive sur une terre
où l'on a l'habitude d'aller,
les cultivateurs nous disent :
"C'est notre terre !"
Partout, tout est vendu.
Nous n'avons plus d'endroit
pour notre bétail.
Nos conflits avec les agriculteurs,
viennent des dégâts causés
par nos animaux dans leurs champs.
Si un bœuf fait des dégâts,
on nous taxe de 40000
à 50000 francs CFA.
L'élevage permet à certains
de s'enrichir sur notre dos.
Les gouvernements se font des millions,
grâce aux taxes qu'ils prélèvent !
Les agriculteurs ne leur
rapportent pas autant.
Les Blancs donnent des aides pour
l'élevage, de l'argent cash.
Mais on n'en a jamais vu la couleur.
Il y a vraiment des fonds qui
arrivent mais on ne voit rien venir.
En tout cas, ça ne vient
pas jusqu'aux éleveurs !
Ils organisent des réunions
comme celle-ci,
ils envoient des représentants
du gouvernement,
qui arrivent avec des piles de dossiers,
jettent un œil sur la situation,
puis repartent en disant aux Blancs
que le boulot est fait.
Et là, ils font un grand séminaire
à N'Djaména qui bouffe tout l'argent !
Les projets échouent car les acteurs
concernés ne sont pas consultés.
C'est planifié dans des bureaux,
et une fois sur le terrain,
ça ne marche pas.
Parce qu'ils ne prennent pas
l'avis des principaux intéressés,
ni celui des éleveurs,
ni celui des agriculteurs.
Un séminaire sur les conflits
agriculteurs-éleveurs,
a été organisé sous l'égide
d'un médiateur national.
Le projet de loi qu'il nous a soumis
nous a fait quitter la salle.
Cette loi était uniquement répressive
et sans aucun avantage pour les éleveurs.
En ce qui concerne les voleurs de bétail,
si tu attrapes un voleur,
et que tu l'amènes aux autorités,
demain ils vont le relâcher.
Et le problème n'est jamais résolu.
Tu es d'abord victime du voleur,
puis victime des autorités.
Ça nous retombe dessus
à tous les coups.
Aujourd'hui, même en brousse,
on n'est plus en sécurité.
Nos bêtes non plus.
Parce que nous avons des bêtes,
nous devons souffrir plus
que ceux qui n'ont rien !
Aucun de nous ici présent
ne peut fermer l'œil.
À cause de ces voleurs de bétail !
Si la nuit, le voleur
tue l'un de nos gardes,
et qu'il prend la fuite,
si l'éleveur y a laissé sa vie,
personne de la police ne s'en soucie !
Si c'est un Peul qui est mort,
on enterre l'histoire.
Par contre,
si c'est le voleur qui est tué,
les autorités viennent fouiller partout,
pour arrêter le coupable.
Et qu'ils le trouvent ou non,
c'est nous qui payons.
À ce train là,
je peux imaginer qu'un jour,
si un serpent est écrasé
par un de nos bœufs,
les autorités nous feront
payer son meurtre !
La multiplication des conflits armés,
s'est accompagnée de l'apparition d'une
nouvelle menace pour les éleveurs nomades.
Ils sont pulvérisés dans les savanes,
ils sont fragiles, ils sont isolés.
Difficultés pour vendre
le bétail, le lait,
mais ils sont accessibles aux bandits
de grand chemin qui se sont multipliés.
Que ce soit au Cameroun à une certaine
époque, le problème a été résolu,
en Centrafrique ce n'est pas du tout
résolu, au Tchad et au Soudan non plus.
Il y a du banditisme et les bandits
avec quelques kalachnikov,
font une descente
dans un petit campement,
maltraitent les gens
qu'ils trouvent sur place,
et les oblige à aller vendre le bétail.
Et ils attendent que l'argent
revienne après la vente du bétail.
Aux dernières nouvelles, en République
centrafricaine, il y aurait à peu près,
30000 éleveurs qui auraient fui
la République centrafricaine,
et ces malversations.
L'Etat, dans certains endroits,
une grosse partie de l'État,
n'est pas contrôlée
par les forces publiques.
Donc, à certains moments, les éleveurs
se sont organisés avec des archers,
mais ils n'étaient pas de taille
à lutter contre les Kalashnikov.
Il y a eu à peu près
30 000 Peuls Bororos,
sur 200 000 qui sont partis,
qui sont retournés au Cameroun,
où il y a une meilleure sécurité.
Le Sénégal, lui,
est un pays où règne la paix.
Ancienne zone de transhumance,
terre de repli pour les bergers peuls,
le Ferlo a subi
de profondes transformations,
encouragées par les campagnes d'hydraulique
pastorales menées dans les années 50,
les éleveurs et leurs familles
se sont partiellement sédentarisés.
Ils se sont regroupés
en minuscule village,
à proximité de mares
et point d'eau permanent.
Pour autant, paix et vie sédentaire
ne riment pas forcément,
avec sécurité pour les animaux.
Avant, tu pouvais laisser
divaguer ton troupeau,
tu pouvais les laisser seuls pendant
des jours, personne n'y touchait.
Maintenant, pour nous les éleveurs,
si tu pars au travail, au retour,
tes bœufs ont été volés.
J'habite Kadiakaye,
c'est mon village d'origine.
Mon grand-père, mon père
et moi-même sommes nés ici.
C'est ici mon origine.
Je suis éleveur et je cultive la terre.
Mais avant tout, je suis un éleveur.
Je suis un éleveur
qui a beaucoup de bœufs.
Il y a 3 mois où tout va bien.
Car pendant la saison des pluie,
il y a à manger et à boire.
Mais passé les trois mois
de saison des pluies,
on doit aller jusqu'au forage.
Si on avait les moyens de faire
venir de l'eau jusqu'à nous,
au lieu de devoir emmener les troupeaux
s'abreuver à 10 km,
Ce serait déjà mieux.
On serait débarrassé de notre
plus gros problème.
C'est un fait, nous avons besoin d'aide,
pour développer l'élevage au Sénégal.
Pour produire de la viande et du lait.
Mais on ne peut pas produire
tout cela à cause de la sécheresse.
Il n'y a plus d'eau
ni de mares pour boire,
ni pâturages.
Il ne faut pas croire que parce
qu'on possède des troupeaux,
on est assez riche
pour se tirer d'affaire.
Les éleveurs n'ont plus
les moyens de s'en sortir !
Passé les trois mois d'hivernage
pour trouver de l'eau,
les bœufs doivent parcourir
de grandes distances.
C'est pour cela qu'ils perdent du poids.
Et ils ne boivent qu'une fois par jour.
Dans ces conditions, les bœufs
ne peuvent pas grossir,
ni se reproduire correctement.
Je m'appelle Mahamka,
je suis né ici et je suis
président du comité rural.
J'ai grandi dans une famille d'éleveurs,
je suis fils d'éleveurs.
Il faut qu'on nous aide,
autant que les cultivateurs.
Il nous faut du matériel
pour travailler.
Il faut que le bidon d'eau
ne nous coûte pas 500 francs.
Il faut qu'on puisse accéder à l'eau,
comme les cultivateurs.
Avec des camions citernes, on pourrait
s'organiser et ramener de l'eau.
Même de loin !
Avant que les rivières ne s'assèchent,
on avait de gros bœufs.
Ils étaient bien nourris.
Ils mangeaient,
s'abreuvaient, se reposaient...
Et d'une ville à l'autre, on trouvait
toujours de quoi s'approvisionner.
Les puits étaient pleins.
Sinon il n'y avait qu'à creuser
pour trouver de l'eau.
Maintenant les bœufs manquent d'eau,
et les vaches ne peuvent
plus allaiter leurs petits.
Autrefois aussi,
les vétérinaires passaient
chez les éleveurs.
Ils faisaient des piqûres aux bœufs
malades et ils guérissaient.
C'était comme ça en ce temps-là.
La quantité de vaccins qu'on
donnait autrefois à quelques bœufs,
sert à vacciner 500 bêtes aujourd'hui.
Les États, traditionnellement,
étaient organisés,
pour faire les campagnes de vaccination,
pour faire les campagnes de déparasitage
et de bain des animaux contre les tiques,
parce que les tiques transmettre
des maladies mortelles.
Avant, c'était l'Etat qui se chargeait,
d'organiser la santé animale et souvent
de la prendre en charge financièrement.
Il y a eu un changement
de stratégie au niveau mondial,
avec la Banque mondiale
et le Fonds monétaire international,
qui ont demandé que finalement
les producteurs prennent en charge,
la totalité des coûts de la santé animale.
Donc, il y a eu démantèlement des systèmes
d'organisation de santé animale,
pour les remplacer par la privatisation.
Finalement, la santé animale
n'est plus assurée,
dans ces zones pastorales extensives,
où la densité est très faible.
Un vétérinaire ne va pas aller
s'installer dans un endroit,
où il y a 3 ou 4 habitants au km carré
et quelques têtes de bétail.
Les Peuls possèdent des connaissances
empiriques salutaires en termes d'élevages.
Ils savent où trouver les pâturages qui
favorisent le bon développement des bêtes,
se débrouillent pour les débarrasser
des parasites, ou soigner leurs infections.
En l'absence de soutien
vétérinaire sérieux,
ils continuent à pratiquer
une médecine traditionnelle de brousse.
Comme le fait aujourd'hui Alagi Shama,
qui, avec une épée chauffée dans
le feu, pratique des incisions,
sur l'une de ses bêtes
qui souffre d'arthrose.
Nous continuons à traiter les
animaux de manière traditionnelle,
avec le feu.
Mais pour certaines maladies,
on aurait besoin d'un vétérinaire.
Aujourd'hui, les docteurs qui passent
voir mes bêtes ne font rien de bon.
Ils ne font qu'amplifier les dégâts.
Les éleveurs peuls ne sont guère mieux
lotis en ce qui concerne leur santé,
et celle de leur famille
ou l'éducation de leurs enfants.
Les dispensaires sont souvent
loin des campements de brousse,
les écoles peu pressés
d'accueillir des enfants,
dont les familles
se déplacent en permanence.
Les éleveurs, en général, souffrent
d'une certaine marginalisation,
institutionnelle, politique.
Et en milieu pastoral, le grand
problème, c'est l'action collective.
Les mouvements,
les organisations qui existent,
ont été créés par l'Etat.
Ils n'ont pas été une initiative
des éleveurs à la base,
de se constituer un groupe, de se battre
pour des questions qui les concernent.
Et la plupart de ces organisations
sont des organisations fantômes.
Ce sont des gens qui ne
sont pas réellement éleveurs,
mais qui sont pour.
Le problème majeur au Sénégal,
c'est qu'il y a l'identité d'éleveurs,
qui s'imbrique à l'identité peul.
Les organisations censées nous représenter
ne sont pas dirigées par des éleveurs.
Ce ne sont que des hommes d'affaires.
Ils ne sont ni éleveurs,
ni agriculteurs.
Et franchement,
est-ce qu'ils connaissent la réalité,
et les problèmes auxquels
nous sommes confrontés ?
Est-ce que les conseillers techniques
et les spécialistes de l'élevage,
font bien leur travail ?
Est-ce l'Etat sénégalais
qui néglige les éleveurs ?
Là, on peut se poser la question !
Est-ce que l'Etat est mal informé ?
Ou est-ce qu'il nous néglige
en connaissance de cause ?
Les éleveurs traditionnels sont accusés de
gérer leur cheptel de manière peu productive.
Et de thésauriser leur capital
en refusant de vendre leurs bêtes,
soustrayant ainsi sa valeur
au circuit économique.
Les chercheurs ont beau démontrer
que cette gestion est productive,
dans le sens où elle s'adapte bien
aux risques sanitaires et économiques,
cette idée a la vie dure.
Le premier terrain,
on est un petit peu surpris.
On a l'impression qu'on est face à une
activité résiduelle des temps anciens,
ou on se dit c'est peut-être
un prolongement au XXIᵉ siècle,
de tradition ethnique dépassée
par la mondialisation.
On se rend compte que dans ce contexte
qui est rempli d'incertitudes,
avec beaucoup de problèmes, ce qui
est visible, on sent la sécheresse...
On se rend compte que finalement,
ils ont réussi,
à développer des comportements économiques
qui sont les mieux adaptés sur ce terrain.
- Je la fais à 225000 francs.
- Moi, je la prends à 150000 !
Non, ce n'est pas le prix.
Je ne la vends pas à ce prix-là.
Alors 152000.
- Tu baisses de combien ?
- Donne 200000.
- Descend encore.
- J'ai déjà baissé de 25000.
- Donne-moi 200000 !
- Diminue encore un peu.
Je veux 200000 pour cette vache.
Allez, 175000 et on n'en parle plus !
Allez, baisse ton prix.
Je le baisse de 5000.
On enlève 5000 de plus,
et on est à 190000 !
Allez, c'est conclu ?
Donne l'argent.
Voilà un acompte.
Demain je complète
et je prends la vache.
Quand demain ?
On est mercredi, demain c'est jeudi,
Samedi je te donne l'argent.
et j'emmène la vache !
Tu lui donnes 1000 francs de commission ?
Oui, c'est moi qui donne
sa commission au témoin.
Marché conclu.
Que dieu nous donne la baraka.
On vend des bêtes
pour acheter de la nourriture.
Des vêtements,
et aussi des médicaments.
Des médicaments
pour soigner notre bétail.
Nous ne faisons rien
d'autre que de l'élevage.
La culture de la terre
n'est pas notre métier.
C'est la vente de notre bétail seul
qui nous permet de satisfaire,
tous nos besoins.
C'est donc du marché que vient
aujourd'hui la plus grande menace,
sur l'avenir de l'élevage
extensif transhumant.
Les éleveurs sahéliens
obligés de vendre des bêtes,
pour acheter de grandes
quantités de mil et Sorgho,
pour nourrir leur famille
en saison sèche,
se retrouvent confrontés
aux manœuvres spéculatives,
de commerçants peu scrupuleux.
La période de soudure,
juste avant la récolte,
quand les gens ont fini leurs greniers,
ils vont devoir acheter.
Et là, la spéculation par les commerçants
va faire monter,
le prix des céréales de 7000 francs,
le sac de 100 kilos à 10 000, 12 000, 20000...
J'ai même vu jusqu'à 40 000 francs le sac.
Les gens étant obligés de manger,
vont vendre du bétail pour acheter ces céréales
qui sont devenus de plus en plus chères.
Comme tout le monde est dans la même
situation, tous ces agro éleveurs,
vont porter le bétail en même
temps sur le marché local,
ce qui va faire effondrer les prix.
Une tête de bétail qui vaut 100 000 CFA,
elle va se négocier
à 80 ou 60 000 francs CFA.
Vous avez d'un côté la spéculation
des céréales qui fait passer le prix,
de 7000 à 20000, en moyenne.
Et en même temps, à cette
période la plus critique,
le bétail va passer
de 100000 à 60 000.
C'est cette double spéculation qui les
met dans la tyrannie des marchés locaux.
Ce qui nous fait mal au Sénégal,
c'est qu'on nous aide moins
que les cultivateurs.
À l'approche de l'hivernage,
on leur prête de l'argent,
Le sac de graines à 50 000 francs,
ils l'obtiennent à moitié prix.
Et pour nous, les éleveurs,
le sac d'aliments pour le bétail,
passe de 8000 à 10000 francs.
Ils ne le baissent pas d'un centime.
Ça nous fait mal parce que
pour pouvoir l'acheter,
il faudrait emprunter à la banque.
Même un troupeau de 500 bœufs,
Ce n'est pas considéré
comme une garantie.
C'est comme ça au Sénégal.
Il faut que les gens sachent que
le gouvernement nous laisse tomber.
Entre 1962 et aujourd'hui,
tout a changé.
Avant, le sac de fourrage
coûtait 75 francs CFA.
Maintenant, il est à 3500 francs
parfois 4000
C'est vraiment plus pareil.
Ce sont les cultivateurs
qui ont augmenté leurs prix.
En fait, tout a augmenté,
les prix ont flambé !
Du coup,
tous les aliments, le fourrage,
les céréales,
les compléments alimentaires,
sont trop chers.
Pour se les payer,
on doit vendre des bêtes.
Un ministère de l'élevage a été créé.
Il y aurait dû y avoir des changements.
Mais jusqu'à présent, de tous
les problèmes posés par l'élevage,
absolument aucun n'a été réglé.
Ils ont dit qu'ils allaient
aider les éleveurs,
parce qu'au fond, ils connaissent
le potentiel de l'élevage.
Mais finalement, ils ne s'intéressent
qu'à leurs ambitions personnelles.
Il y a un conflit d'attente,
il y a un conflit d'objectifs.
L'état, ce qui l'intéresse, c'est,
la fourniture en viande
et en lait des centres urbains,
la fourniture de produits animaux,
alors que le peul n'a pas l'impression
d'être un fournisseur de viande.
C'est un éleveur d'animaux avec
une relation assez particulière,
avec les animaux,
avec une gestion assez particulière,
on a l'impression qu'il y a
un malentendu dès le départ.
Le gouvernement ne nous aide pas.
S'il veut nous aider, il doit empêcher
les éleveurs étrangers,
d'entrer dans le pays.
Sinon ils tuent notre production.
Ces éleveurs qui viennent de Mauritanie,
de Gambie, du Mali.
Ils vendent leurs moutons
et repartent du Sénégal avec l'argent.
Ça me fait mal.
La frontière Gambienne
est à moins de 300 km.
Tu ne peux pas faire rentrer un kilo
de sucre sans payer une taxe.
Les frontières voisines laissent entrer
des troupeaux entiers au Sénégal.
Alors que les nôtres
ne peuvent pas sortir du pays.
Sénégal, marché hebdomadaire
dans le Ferlo.
La dernière menace vient des stocks
de viandes subventionnés,
importés d'Europe et d'Amérique latine.
De 50 000 tonnes
à la fin des années 80,
les quantités importées atteignent
aujourd'hui plus de 200 000 tonnes.
Une viande vendue à bas prix.
Les États ont besoin de viande
la moins chère possible,
pour nourrir leur population,
notamment des villes.
Mais c'est en sacrifiant
leurs filières de productions animales.
Les Sahéliens quand ils amènent
la viande à 600 Francs CFA,
et que les Européens exportent,
sur les marchés de la côte
africaine à 400 francs,
la petite ménagère à Abidjan par exemple,
quand elle ouvre son porte-monnaie,
elle voit qu'elle n'a pas beaucoup
d'argent. Entre la viande à 400,
qui est de la viande congelée
à 30% de graisse,
mais qui est de la viande très correcte,
et de la viande dont elle a l'habitude
de zébu à 600, elle va acheter à 400.
Donc mon sahélien, il est obligé de baisser
le prix de sa viande s'il veut la vendre.
Mais lui, il a toujours besoin
d'une tonne de céréales à acheter,
donc il est contraint
de vendre du bétail.
Tchad, marché au bétail de Mao.
L'élevage a servi ce pays
pendant près de 70 ans,
et aujourd'hui, il est sous-estimé
à cause du pétrole !
Avant, les principales ressources
étaient le transport et lélevage.
Et avec le pétrole,
tout cela a été abandonné !
Le Tchad, grand pays d'élevage,
a longtemps fourni ses voisins
en viande fraiche.
Un grand abattoir a été construit
à N'Djamena dans les années 50,
pour approvisionner
les exportations de viande,
vers une dizaine de pays qui vont
du Bénin à l'Arabie Saoudite.
Avec le renchérissement
des prix du transport,
et la concurrence de la viande importée
d'Europe et d'Amérique Latine,
cette filière d'exportation
a été mise à mal.
et l'abattoir ne tourne plus
au maximum de sa capacité.
Un débouché de moins
pour les éleveurs africains.
Vers les années 70,
on exportait plus de 11 000 tonnes,
de viande fraîche vers le Congo,
les deux Congo : Congo Populaire et Zaïre.
Et ça marchait très bien.
Aujourd'hui, il y a des gens
qui envoient de la viande congelée,
à partir de l'Argentine et d'ailleurs,
qui arrive au Zaïre
avec un prix moins cher.
Alors quand vous vous présentez
avec votre viande du Tchad,
et que son prix s'établit aujourd'hui
à plus de 2000 francs CFA le kilo,
ça ne marche pas !
Et le monde actuel, surtout africain.
est pour la quantité
au lieu de la qualité.
Ceux qui transhument ont de belles bêtes,
par rapport à ceux qui restent sur place.
Même sur le marché,
elles sont vendues
à un prix très intéressant.
L'élevage en principe,
si on s'en occupe bien,
ça remplace le pétrole,
je peux oser dire ça.
Ça peut rapporter comme le pétrole,
Le cheptel tchadien, c'est un don.
Et il n'est pas prêt d'être épuisé.
Au niveau international,
nous Européens
et spécialement les Français,
parce que dans les années 90,
l'exportation des viandes
européennes à 42%,
était de la viande française.
Donc nous, Européens,
nous sommes responsables, partiellement,
on a vu que localement,
il y avait des problèmes,
mais sur le plan international,
les viandes subventionnées,
les 140 000 ou les 200 000 tonnes
qui arrivent maintenant,
sur les pays de la côte, nous
sommes partiellement responsables,
de la décapitalisation
des producteurs sahéliens,
Donc de leur paupérisation.
Mais on ne les entend pas parce qu'ils
sont insuffisamment organisés.
On a entendu les producteurs
cotonniers à l'OMC s'exprimer.
Il n'y a pas encore, bien que les prémices
de l'Organisation internationale des éleveurs,
qui existe mais qui pour l'instant
est une coquille assez vide,
qui n'a pas la puissance
des cotonniers africains,
des organisations
de producteurs cotonniers,
mais il faut arriver
à ça pour pouvoir discuter,
à la table des négociations de l'OMC.
Il y a des choses qui, à mon avis,
ne sont pas normales.
S'il n'y a pas de changement
dans les accords internationaux,
notamment sur le problème de la viande,
je crains qu'ils se paupérisent jusqu'à
finir leur bétail et se transformer,
comme j'ai vu en Centrafrique,
en pêcheurs au bord d'un lac.
Vous avez un peul bororos qui n'a plus
d'animaux et qui est pêcheur, c'est tout.
Ce sera vraiment la condamnation
d'un mode de vie et d'une société,
fabuleuse sur le plan de l'élevage.
La possible disparition
des pasteurs peuls nomades,
n'est-elle pas une occasion
de repenser notre façon d'avancer.
Dans une époque faite d'aléas climatiques
et d'incertitude économique,
leur mode de vie mobile et flexible,
respectant un équilibre
entre l'homme et la nature,
est riche d'enseignements
pour nos sociétés inquiètes.
Le système pastoral ancestral
des éleveurs peuls,
accompagné et amélioré,
pourrait préfigurer de nouveaux
modes de survie pour l'homme de demain.